in la france le royaume uni et
l'allemagne alliés des etats unis se
sont abstenus
washington dénonce un vote inexcusable
nous n'avons besoin d'aucun gouvernement
étranger d'aucun médiateur le président
biélorusse rejette la possibilité d'une
médiation étrangère proposé notamment
par la pologne en difficulté face à
d'importantes contestations post
électorales
alexandre loukachenko s'est entretenu
aujourd'hui avec vladimir poutine
[Musique]
deux cent mille morts 6 millions de cas
de contamination l'amérique latine est
le continent le plus touché du monde par
le cos buts 19 le brésil le mexique le
pérou ce ne sont pas épargnés les
systèmes de santé des différents pays
sont mises à rude épreuve et accentue
les inégalités
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
retrouver sur rtl france depuis 75 ans
d'histoire des nations unies l'amérique
n'a jamais été si isolé à déclaration de
la diplomatie iranienne après le rejet
du conseil de sécurité de l'onu de
prolonger l'embargo sur les ventes
d'armes en iran la chine et la russie
ont voté contre et les principaux alliés
des américains se sont abstenu un vote
qualifié d' inexcusable par washington
hélène masculine les états unis plus que
jamais isolé dans leur croisade contre
l'iran approuvé par deux pays seulement
rejeté par la chine et la russie
les 11 autres membres du conseil se sont
abstenus sur le vote de la résolution
américaine
parmi eux la france le royaume-uni ou
encore l'allemagne
alliée traditionnelle des états unis un
vote inexcusable dénonce washington les
états unis n'abandonneront jamais nos
amis dans la région qui attendent
davantage du conseil de sécurité
nous continuerons à travailler pour
faire en sorte que le régime
théocratique terroristes ne soit pas
libre d'acheter de vendre des armes qui
menace le coeur de l'europe du
moyen-orient et au-delà
le texte américain appelle à une
extension illimité de l'embargo dont
l'expiration en octobre prochain a été
fixé par l'accord international sur le
nucléaire iranien signé en 2015
téhéran n'a pas manqué de relever
l'échec américain depuis 75 ans
d'histoire des nations unies l'amérique
n'a jamais été si isolé un vote sanction
pour washington donald trump s'est
retiré de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien en mai 2018 avant d'imposer une
série de sanctions unilatérales à l'iran
une méthode remise en cause par les
membres du conseil de sécurité notamment
la délégation française
la fin de l'embargo pourrait avoir de
graves conséquences pour la sécurité et
la stabilité régionale cependant la
france s'est abstenue sur le projet de
résolution proposé car il ne constitue
pas une réponse adaptée
ce rejet de l'onu entache la crédibilité
américaine sur la scène internationale
dans un communiqué publié après le vote
les etats-unis affirment qu'ils ne
reculeront devant rien pour prolonger
l'embargo sur les ventes d'armes à
l'iran
écoutez toujours à ce sujet
alice de morad el hattab l'écrivain et
géopolitologue d'abord les américains
s'attendaient à cette prise de décision
déjà dans les couloirs on savait que le
prolongement de l'embargo à n'allait pas
être conduit en raison du fait que ça
risque de mettre à mal les accords sur
le nucléaire avec l'iran
donc ce n'est pas une surprise et puis
le seul pays qui a signé avec les
américains c'est la république
dominicaine autant vous dire que ça pèse
pas grand chose au niveau international
la priorité des américains celle
pacifique sur le plan géopolitique et
stratégique
donc les américains vont rentrer dans la
négociation je voulais dit ils n'ont pas
fait état de leur statut de participant
donc ça veut dire que les négociations
vont commencer à santa mai et puis j'ai
envie de dire pour la stabilité mondiale
il vaut mieux quelque part avoir un
droit de regard sur ce qui est en train
de faire l'iran sur le plan nucléaire et
c'est à ce prix qu'on leur a tête à tête
téléphonique entre vladimir poutine et
alexandre lukashenko le président
biélorusse affirme que le chef du
kremlin lui a assuré une aide
sécuritaire
le pays est en effet en proie à un
important mouvement de contestation
depuis dimanche et la réélection un
sixième mandat d' alexandre lukashenko à
des manifestations qui se poursuivent
quotidiennement c'était encore le cas
aujourd'hui à miscou ils étaient des
milliers
réunis dans un communiqué le kremlin
affirme que les problèmes que connaît la
biélorussie elles sont en passe d'être
résolue alexandre loukachenko a informé
son homologue russe de la situation en
biélorussie après l'élection
présidentielle
les deux parties ont exprimé leur
conviction que tous les problèmes
actuels seront bientôt résolus
le plus important étant que ces
problèmes ne soit pas exploité par des
forces destructrices qui s'efforce de
nuire à la coopération mutuellement
avantageuse entre les deux pays dans le
cadre de l'union de la russie et de la
biélorussie la réélection d'alexandre
loukachenko est fortement contesté aussi
bien en biélorussie qu'à l'international
mais le chef d'état biélorusse rejette
toute proposition de médiation étrangère
nous pouvons voir ce qui se passe nous
n'avons pas besoin de nous laisser
bercer par des actions et des
manifestations pacifiques
nous voyons ce qui se passe au fond on
le voit très bien et puis on lit les
manuels des révolutions de couleur de
plus outre les manuels de révolution de
couleur
on voit déjà des éléments
d'interférences externe c'est ce que
j'ai dit en fait selon le scénario
l'agression contre la biélorussie est en
cours une situation qui a démarré le 9
août au soir après l'annoncé de la
victoire d'alexandre loukachenko à
l'élection présidentielle est les
resultats le donnent vainqueur du
scrutin avec plus de 80% des voix
s'ensuit une série de manifestations
retour en images sur une semaine agitée
en biélorussie
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour bruno drv qu'historien est
maître de conférences à l'inalco les
sanctions annoncées par l'union
européenne air seront symboliques pour
ne pas froisser le gouvernement
biélorusse
la réaction de l'union européenne est
intéressante dans la mesure où on parle
de sanction est pour le moment les
sanctions annoncées sont des sanctions
plutôt symbolique puisqu'elle vise les
personnes les dirigeants de biélorussie
qui de toute façon n'était pas
véritablement en odeur de sainteté dans
les pays de l'union européenne donc mon
impression c'est que l'union européenne
d'un côté voudrait faire pression sur
minsk mais pas trop pour éviter
évidemment que la biélorussie ne se
rapprochent trop de son voisin oriental
c'est à dire de la russie dont il ya un
jeu compliqué entre certains pays
membres de l'union européenne qui
veulent pousser aux sanctions et
d'autres qui veulent freiner les
sanctions pour maintenir les
négociations avec le gouvernement de
minsk
pas de vacances pour alléger les jaunes
qui ont de nouveau battu le pavé ce
samedi apparaît le cortège est parti de
bercy direction à la place de la nation
les revendications sont les mêmes depuis
la création du mouvement une
manifestation encadrée par un important
dispositif policier mais qui s'est
déroulé dans le calme et précision de
notre reporter kirill kotick of les
gilets jaunes prépare déjà la rentrée ce
samedi se sont donnés rendez vous sur
les marches du palais omnisports de
paris bercy aux alentours de midi avant
que le cortège ne démarre à 14h30 les
revendications des gilets jaunes n'ont
pas changé référendum d'initiative
citoyenne lutte contre les inégalités
sociales hausse du smic et des pensions
de retraite retrait de la csg
le cortège a emprunté la rue de reuilly
en direction de la place de la bastille
puis de la place de la nation où les
manifestants se sont dispersés dans le
calme aux alentours de 18 heures aucune
violence malgré quelques petites
bousculades avec les forces de l'ordre
en cause le refus de certains magasins
de laisser leurs établissements ouverts
lors du passage du cortège alors que
certains manifestants voulaient se
ravitailler en eau est à noter aussi le
non-respect malheureusement des gestes
barrières au sein d'un cortège plutôt
dense d'environ 300 personnes avec
parfois des slogans hostiles au port du
masque une manifestation qui a
finalement
pris fin dans le plus grand calme à son
arrivée sur la place de la nation aux
alentours de 18 heures et pour parler de
cette nouvelle manifestation le gilet
jaune avec nous patrick bach angbo
chercheur en droit public et sociologues
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors ni les vacances ni la
chaleur ni le kobe 19 n'aura eu la peau
des gilet jaune
ils ont repris le chemin des
ronds-points et les manifestations ont
repris
comment expliquer que ce mouvement de
contestation né en novembre 2018 elle
soit toujours actif après tout ce temps
on sera le mouvement des gilet jaune
quand j'ai eu l'occasion de les dire sur
vos antennes incertaine fois c'est un
mouvement qui s'inscrit dans la durée ce
n'est pas un mouvement ponctuelle les
revendications étaient caractérisées au
début par une certes été cristallisée au
début par une forte contestation contre
les mesures de hausse des prix du
carburant mais aussi une écologie
punitive que certains avaient pressenti
mais aussi la baisse de la vitesse sur
les routes nationales
mais aujourd'hui ce mouvement se veut un
mouvement dans la durée dans la durée
d'abord pour faire face à un pouvoir
politique qui est face à keane était
facilement qui est presque seul sur clio
qui occupent le terrain presque seul ce
qui n'a pas vraiment de répondant au
plan politique de manière pleine et qui
doit faire face directement contestation
soit de la population soit des corps
intermédiaires c'est à dire les
syndicats comme on l'a vu en décembre
dernier voilà pourquoi les gilets jaunes
ne peuvent passer des baisses débattre
pavés et dans le contexte actuel la
crise économique liée à l'épidémie de
kovy 19 les discours des gilets jaunes a
un retentissement beaucoup plus
important que d'ordinaire
parce que tout le monde sait que la
population française va être sévèrement
concernés par les retombées économiques
notamment financières et en termes
d'emploi pour les salariés mais aussi en
ce qui concerne la politique sociale et
le gouvernement sur ce plan a montré
bien sûr de la volonté mais simplement
les discours d
les jeunes prend tout son sens à partir
du moment où le gouvernement est amené à
courir un petit peu derrière la cour
derrière la crise afin de pouvoir
pallier les difficultés économiques
auxquelles font face en face les
français alors sur fond de crise
sanitaire liée aux kobe 19 la france
comme de nombreux autres pays a
restreint certaines libertés notamment
celle de manifester
la préfecture de police de paris
interdit désormais tout rassemblement de
plus de 10 personnes si les gestes
barrière ne sont pas respectées certains
estiment que cette mesure a pour but de
bloquer une rentrée sociale qui
s'annonce mouvementée qu'en pensez vous
ça peut être dans ce sens puisqu'il faut
il faut dénoter un petit peu une sorte
d'anachronisme dans l'action d'une sur
des contradictions notoire dans l'action
de la préfecture de police de paris le
même jour ou en étant là en étant
l'obligation du port du masque dans les
rues et dans les quartiers de paris
c'est maintenant plus de 60% de paris
qui et contre l'avis des parties
concernées par l'obligation du port du
masque le même jour on autorise une
manifestation sachant pertinemment que
les gestes barrière né seront pas
respectées puisque il est très difficile
de respecter des gestes barrières dans
une manifestation qui est dynamique
lorsqu'on est statique ça peut se
comprendre ça peut se faire
mais lorsqu'on est dans une position
dynamique c'est-à-dire on s'est déplacé
difficile d'encadrer des gens dans ce
domaine là est la réponse de la
préfecture de police il faut aussi la
comprendre dans le sens où le préfet a
et didier lallement a été sévèrement
critiqué par son action à cause de son
action qui était une action anti preuves
précises pour qui était une action sans
c'est un petit peu occupé le terrain
découragé les manifestants aient essayé
parfois dîné à celle et d'une certaine
manière afin de pouvoir faire échec à
toute tentative de détendre les
mouvements sociaux dans la capitale
c'est aussi un petit peu une politique
ambiguë que à laquelle se livre la
préfecture de police de paris
mais on n'est pas dupe pour comprendre
que la rentrée sociale sera très très
mouvementée surtout à partir du moment
où les chiffres du chômage les chiffrer
le palais récent mais les chiffres réels
vont tomber à la rentrée c'est à dire
dès le mois de septembre et qu'on
connaîtra toutes les catastrophes au
plan économique mais aussi en termes
d'emplois que l'épidémie d'e.coli 19
aura causé alors beaucoup de gilet jaune
estime ne pas être suffisamment voire
pas du tout entendu par emmanuel macron
et son gouvernement
il estime qu'il ya aujourd'hui une vraie
fracture entre la classe dirigeante et
une partie de la population dont ils
font partie
votre analyse sur le sujet vous êtes
d'accord
oui parce que leur discours est un petit
peu de parfois pris de manière on peut
dire légère ou d'une manière un petit
peu déconcertante si je prends l'exemple
par exemple si je prends l'exemple du
riq le référendum d'initiative citoyenne
le président du sénat gérard larcher a
repris l'idée selon lui en disant qu' il
pas question du rich or est dans le
système démocratie représentative tels
que la vème république l'a conçu mais
simplement quand il ya une des pétitions
qui atteignent un certain nombre de
votes ça peut faire l'objet d'une loi
qui serait traité en premier lieu au
sénat avant d'être envoyé à l'assemblée
nationale ça n'a aucun sens en réalité
puisque ça veut dire simplement que la
population doit de toute façon dépendre
de ses élus or les gilets jaunes veulent
une participation directe parce que ça
qu'on appelle la démocratie
participative aux décisions les plus
importantes du pays et les jets les
jeunes veulent aussi avoir la
possibilité de peser sur les animateurs
des institutions pas sur les
institutions elles mêmes mais sur leurs
animaux et l alliance animateurs avoir
la possibilité de révoquer certains qui
sont présentés comme ne pas faire leur
travail correctement
mais il jusque là et force est de
constater que deux ans presque deux ans
après le début du mouvement de gilet
jaune et il n'y a pas de réponse
concrète concernant les revendications
de gilet jaune et c'est ce que nous
avons essayé nous à l'université paris
saclay l'université d'evry val d'essonne
de traiter dans un ouvrage récent qui
est sorti les gilets jaunes au prisme du
droit dans lesquels je signe
un chapitre intitulé gilet jaune et
l'égalité territoriale donc dans cet
ouvrage nous reprenons un petit peu les
revendications des pardons rapidement
s'il vous plaît à sa fin oui sa part
dans c'est justement pour présenter les
révendications gilet jaune en termes
juridiques et comment les traduire
justement des réponses concrètes au plan
législatif et au plan réglementaire
patrick bas congo merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes chercheur en droit public et
sociologue également merci beaucoup
la menace d'une deuxième vague de kobe
de 19 plane sur l'europe
en france le dernier bilan fait état de
deux mille huit cent quarante six
nouveaux cas en 24 heures l'espagne
connaît aussi une situation inquiétante
avec près de 3000 nouveaux car le pays
on confine à nouveau plusieurs communes
au royaume uni une 14 elle est imposée
aux voyageurs en provenance de france de
malte et des pays bas le royaume uni qui
compte pour sa part 1441 nouveaux cas de
contamination en 24 heures c'est
officiel un le masque est désormais
obligatoire en extérieur dans plusieurs
lieux de la capitale parisienne
notamment sur l'avenue des champs
elysées une décision qui divise les
parisiens même si la plupart semblent
être plutôt rassurés par cette mesure
moi pour moi c'est du positif
je me sens plus en sécurité conçoit
qu'autour de moi tout le monde à un
masque et je pense que c'est l'attitude
que tout le monde devrait avoir en fait
d'une première chose c'est préventif
donc si c'est préventif
je préfère qu'on le fasse c'est qu'on
risque rien que qu'on fasse la même des
mêmes erreurs que qu'avant le
confinement à quai les champs-elysées ce
soit obligatoire peut comprendre on ne
peut pas le faire l'autorisé ailleurs et
pas ici enfin
pour moi c'est tout à fait normal et ça
reste quand même l'avenue la plus
fréquente est donc elle doit être
ils doivent prendre des mesures aussi
restrictive mais est-ce que c'est
suffisant je sais pas est-ce que porter
un masque c'est suffisant je sais pas si
la pandémie gagnait du terrain également
en amérique latine c'est le continent le
plus touché du monde par le cos vie de
19 200 mille morts et 6 millions de cas
de contamination un virus qui met en
exergue les inégalités des systèmes de
santé de nombreux pays et mediascape
fusion triste record pour l'amérique
latine
loin d'être épargné par la crise ducobu
de 19 la région est désormais la plus
touchés au monde
le pérou voit sa courbe de contamination
augmenter chaque jour même phénomène en
colombie et en argentine
principale explication des systèmes de
santé précaire dans des pays parfois en
retard sur le plan médical à buenos
aires et laisse les autorités n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de miser sur une
fréquentation maîtrisé dans les
établissements de soins est longue et
nécessite 30 qui ce dont nous avons
besoin c'est que le système ne soit pas
saturer afin que nous puissions
continuer comme nous le faisons et si
nous le faisons c'est parce que nous
doublons nous gagnons du temps pour le
système de santé argentin nous le
multiplions et je n'ai pas été obsédé
par la quarantaine je suis obsédée par
la santé des argentins je n'apprécie pas
une quarantaine qui n'existent pas parce
que cela fait plusieurs mois que
l'argentine n'a oublié la quarantaine et
si quelqu'un en doute il suffit de
sortir dans les rues et devant les
commerces ouverts et les gens qui
circulent et viana la chaîne tesco là
malgré la mise en place de mesures de
restriction les gestes barrières ont du
mal à être respectés tout comme le
confinement
autre problème plus d'un sixième des
latinos-américains habitent dans des
bidonvilles zones où la promiscuité est
omniprésente et où l'accès à l'eau reste
difficile cette flambée épidémique
pousse les états à trouver des solutions
pour anticiper l'avenir
le gouvernement mexicain a décidé de
produire le vaccin actuellement
développé par le laboratoire astrazeneca
celui ci devrait être prêt pour le
premier trimestre
de l'année 2021 pour donner des
garanties à tous notre pays tous les
mexicains vont avoir accès au vaccin il
ne faut pas se préoccuper des pauvres on
leur garantit l'accès au vaccin
llorente progrès c'est le projet de
vaccin qui à l'heure actuelle est
considéré comme le plus avancé au monde
selon les études cliniques disponibles
c'est un vaccin qui est en phase 3 on
estime que les résultats de la phase iii
après que les phases une et deux et eu
des résultats très positifs seront
présentés d'ici le mois de novembre
un vaccin destination de l'amérique
latine dont le pérou qui connaît une
hausse constante des cas de colonna
virus face à cette situation le
gouvernement péruvien récemment interdit
les rassemblements familiaux
le pays reste très vulnérable à
l'épidémie notamment à cause du manque
de moyens d'après la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie franco péruvienne le pays
consacre seulement 4% de son pib à la
santé contre une moyenne de 7 5% en
amérique latine les populations sud
américaines ne sont pas suffisamment
armés pour lutter contre le virus
explications de claudio kalfon kir
secrétaire exécutif national du parti de
gauche et spécialiste de l'amérique
latine
alors il est difficile de dire qu' ils
sont armés lorsqu'ils ont été dépouillés
pendant des décennies aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'ils sont armés vraisemblablement bas
au niveau qu'il qu'il faudrait
maintenant il n'est vrai il est bien sûr
pas trop tard pour encore mettre tous
les moyens nécessaires etc comme l'a été
comme l'a rappelé au mexique
andré manuel lopez obrador où il est il
ya une nécessité de trouver bien sûr un
vaccin mais aussi d'autres mais d'autres
médicaments pour pouvoir mettre à
disposition de l'ensemble de la
population et de ne pas faire de
différence entre les différents les
différentes classes sociales car
l'amérique latine ce qu'est le ce
qu'elle souffre c'est vous l'avez
rappelé c'est exactement ça un sixième
des des latino américains qui vivent
dans les bidonvilles sacré bien
évidemment des dégâts le pérou est le
sixième pays le plus touché du monde par
la pandémie les victimes se comptent par
milliers parmi elles la famille dias qui
a perdu cinq de ses proches
grégoire douce est une véritable
hécatombe au sein d'un même foyer
la crise sanitaire du coc vite 19 s'est
transformé en cauchemar éveillé pour la
famille dias alors que ses membres dont
pas identifier l'origine de la
contamination
le virus s'est répandu comme une traînée
de poudre dans leur maison les deux
parents ont été emportées en plus de
trois des sept membres de la fratrie est
à mes armes a nommé no look est sur le
mur c'est une photo de mon petit frère
qui nous a quittés il y a deux mois
après lui mon père est mort et la
semaine suivante ma soeur qui était son
infirmière est morte également et une
semaine plus tard ce sont ma mère et mon
autre frère le dernier de la famille qui
sont décédés outre le déchirement les
dias vivent dans l'angoissé de devoir
compter de nouveaux défunt au sein de la
famille quatre autres personnes sont
encore malades et hospitalisés
malgré une douleur extrêmement vive ceux
qui sont encore présents pour habiter la
maison de briques familiale espère
désormais tant bien que mal retrouver
une vie ordinaire ou presque on va
maintenant voir quelles décisions
peuvent être prises pour maintenir la
famille unie retrouver un bien-être et
entre guillemets le retour à la normale
une normalité qui ne reviendra
certainement pas soudainement mais qui
se manifestera plus où
au fur et à mesure que la vie avant le
pérou compte désormais plus d'un demi
million de contamination confirmés
déplorant pas loin de 26 mille décès
situation très tendue en côte d'ivoire à
la proche du scrutin présidentiel du 31
octobre
cinq personnes sont mortes et plus d'une
centaine ont été blessées dans des
manifestations contre la candidature un
troisième mandat du président ouattara
le gouvernement a mis en garde les
contestataires et affiche je cite sa
détermination à ne pas laisser
s'installer le désordre pourtant la
constitution ivoirienne limite à deux le
nombre de mandats présidentiels
sauf que les partisans du président
estime qu'une réforme adapté en 2016
remet le compteur des mandats à 0
l'opposition est en désaccord avec cette
interprétation
une candidature du président ivoirien
dénoncées également à paris où plusieurs
dizaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées place du trocadéro elles ont
réclamé la libération des prisonniers
politiques ainsi que le retour de
l'ancien président laurent gbagbo a
privé de passeport ivoirien il est
actuellement en liberté conditionnelle
en belgique
écoutez ces quelques réactions de
manifestants parisiens
nous constatons que le président en
place est en train de violer
complètement ici la prostitution qui est
le socle même qu'un pays et nous sommes
ici donc pour dit non à un troisième
mandat satie soit la raison de troisième
mandat n'a pas sa place
passer lui-même sa propre constitution
qui la recherchent un demi la saison
allant d'une troisième république ne lui
donne pas assez à faire trois étages et
nous voulons que tous les présents
africain passe demandent à 7,2 mona qui
est bon parce que avec deux mandats et
ça permet la démocratie en en fuite
ça permet aussi à d'autres à d'autres de
ne pas faire deux mandats
et ça ça a dû lui aussi la guerre c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi la prochain point sur l'actualité
dans un peu plus d'une demi-heure rester
avec nous sur rt france
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]